prot
[Musique]
bercé par la voix de bono que le
cercueil de samuel pâtit après ça on
n'en prit dans la cour d'honneur de la
sorbonne cet antre du savoir qui incarne
l'esprit des lumières nout de ce lion
camarade christophe capuano un amuse
collègues enseignants a été à la demande
de sa famille discrète mais au coeur du
jury monique le premier à prendre la
parole
bien des choses changeront adieu s'amuse
s'habitue entre les statuts de victor
hugo et pasteur un peu de poésie meta
pour subjuguer la doula paraît qu'on
s'habitue aux horreurs qu'on vit la
méline ou son contenu on ne s'habitue
pas le président emmanuel macron venait
de remettre à la famille de samuel pâtit
la médaille de la légion d'honneur la
plus haute distinction de france
je ne parlerai pas de ceux qui ont livré
son nom aux barbares ils ne le méritent
pas le président a dénoncé ces lâches
avant de rendre hommage au fils offerts
ou collègues à l'enseignant samuel bâti
fille tuée parce que les islamistes
veulent notre futur et qu'ils savent
qu'avec des héros tranquille tels que
lui ils ne l'auront jamais aux grands
hommes la patrie reconnaissante au pied
du panthéon des centaines d'anonymes ont
pu suivre les hommages dans un
recueillement empreint de respect samuel
dati était un professeur sans histoire
qui aimait passionnément l'histoire si
bien samuel patty est devenu vendredi le
visage de la république de notre volonté
de briser les terroristes de réduire les
islamistes de vivre comme une communauté
de citoyens libres dans notre pays
le visage de notre détermination à
comprendre à apprendre a continué
d'enseigner à être libre
car nous continuerons professeurs ce
soir c'est la promesse solennelle de
toute une nation
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada paris